alright ladies and gentlemen welcome
back to your favorite podcast you know
the name
[Music]
voices back anyway this is singing Mike
and I always offer the singing mic to
the guests
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's fine yeah people like just
singing Mike I don't know how I started
it or when I started it but like I was
doing songs and stuff and then like you
know what would a stressful morning I've
had yeah but we're gonna talk about you
know what welcome to the podcast
by the way popular demand yeah I've been
getting a lot of tweets and stuff people
like you know so here he is ladies and
gentlemen welcome to the briefing with
Griffin for the first time by popular
demand mr. red ban thank you yeah we had
a live audience but um anyways welcome
dude thanks for coming thanks for having
me man you know I always like having
people on the podcast that I haven't
like had a like a full-on conversation
with and it's like we pass each other in
the hallway we're cordial we say hi
things like that but we I don't know if
we've ever like sat down I've been like
hey who are you
right like what's going on in your life
yeah
a lot of podcasts I know right yeah cuz
even back in the day I remember doing
one of your podcasts you would weren't
you in charge of a podcast it was at out
of the Icehouse yeah I used to have a
studio at the ice house or my studio was
at the Ice House for eight years and I
feel like you do like this Sam Tripoli
naughty show with Sam Tripoli
Wow well here well well here you are
yeah you you been on the podcast game
from the jump yeah for a long time I
think first started out with doing the
Joe Rogan podcast started that with
Rogen coming up on 10 years this miss
December yeah we're about to celebrate
that next week so Wow
yeah and then I took a took a kind of a
break because I was doing like 12
podcasts a week oh wow like I was I mean
I was doing like Sam tripolis Tom Segura
started that one up and I a bunch of
them and then I kind of burnt myself out
so I kind of did the I just only did
kill Tony for a couple years
yeah usually which you're still long yep
I still do that and the sound effects
guy on kill Tony yeah somehow that
became was it was co-host it's more like
Tony summit talks so much talking anyway
so it's like more like I'll just it's 20
he talks [ __ ] about you when he comes on
here he talked about how you and
Jeremiah like eat like [ __ ] trash on the
road he's so funny because he actually
eats more trash than I know I mean not
more than Jeremiah but he's always the
one like even put on our writer anytime
we go to a new city that we have to have
the local pizza that's so like we just
got back so glad you know yeah this
little [ __ ] on my part oh yeah yeah yeah
like every city we go to on my rider is
a Powerade zero oh that's it and that's
it but he has a pizza and so like we
just got back we did three different
cities Ohio and Pittsburgh Cleveland
whatever and every city we had a pizza I
was like come on man like look like we
eat so much pizza like I usually if I'm
just home maybe once a week I'll go you
know lets us have a pie but we're big
guys like a good piece yeah but after
three in a row yeah I didn't think did
Tony would be like a rider girl but
that's how I think about as I know him
more I feel like yeah he's well I didn't
refer a green M&Ms type guy I think it's
all his people like like hey day you
know they wanted
if you want anything on the writer now
they would have asked me that like I
would have just said yes some sandwich
meat maybe a fruit plate
you know something mellow yeah
I had a club owner show me a really
weird rider once he was a he was he this
rider and I remember it was like I'm not
gonna say the club but I will say the
comic was Charlie Murphy I already know
this is and it was just like some we
know no that's Eddie Griffin
Eddie Griffin's the shoes that's isn't
that weird how famous that is that
everybody knows he asked for Air Force
Ones yeah absolutely
Ammar if he could still demand those
like it doesn't ever like did your
demands ever be like it's now Skechers
slippers you get when you get your toes
done
nobody it was a girl with such a weird
rod it was like yeah he had Newports
like a box at like a box of Cardinal
imports and it was it was very I was
like wow this is like I've never thought
I don't think I've made it like that
where I feel like I can ask for
something strange yeah I was on the road
for a month with Murphy and Charlie
Murphy and Rogen and John Heffron we did
this whole comedy thing wine a comedy
tour oh wow
and it was so great hanging out with
Charlie Murphy he was one of the nicest
guys ever and as Buddy Rich r.i.p you
know I mean yeah yeah that was a hard
one yeah and out of nowhere for me oh
really
yeah I saw maybe like a month before
that you know he passed and had no idea
you know I find this is such a strange
small community that we have this little
Brotherhood that you know it's like I
would never think that you would know
Charlie much yeah you know right but
it's just one of those things where you
go you talk to somebody they go well you
know I actually opened for you know yeah
yeah yeah it was mostly because through
Rogan you know because I used to fall
Rogan around open up for Rogan on the
road like you know how Tony does now
yeah and I did that for years and years
and it's Justin through Rogan I met all
these people so it's it's kind of cool
it's like a cheat code to moving into
Los Angeles you know you've made a good
name for yourself the fact that people
are like asking for you to be on certain
podcast you've done Rogan a few times
right oh man
five hundred I think I was the co-host
whenever I wasn't in
- yeah podcasts yes I wouldn't know
about that it was like it was like it's
funny cuz I feel like the comics that
realized the podcasting could be a thing
y'all kept that real quiet cuz no one
knew about it it was so funny it was
like when it blew up it was like I had
to actually go to people like re and Tom
is like come on let's do a podcast I
know how to do it I'm doing Rogen's and
look how successful that's becoming let
me make one for you so that's like how
you know that's how people's all the
people I knew got into this meet begging
them like dude you don't understand it's
gonna help you out you know you do you
do you regret not having some kind of
like 5% contract and it goes to the
please don't forget me yeah they all
forgotten you you know re re you know
recently had me on his podcast and we
did like a three-hour podcasts all about
how the beginnings of it and how much he
appreciated me it was like a very sweet
podcast and then like literally a week
later Sam Adams had me on one of their
commercials with Ari of him also just
going hey dude you know it was oh yeah
that's mine that turned out amazing so
yeah
Ari's definitely feeling like they
appreciates me but then you know the
other guys they don't get [ __ ] okay yeah
now but anyways um let's talk about this
thing I had this weird morning cuz and I
know you can relate cuz you have a Tesla
sure do you have a Tesla now do you have
a charging station where you live I have
a unfortunately I live in an apartment
but luckily where I park there's a
little power outlet which is if you know
if you have a Tesla it's like something
it's not the same as I think if you plug
it in you get 4 miles an hour oh you
know but what's great is you plug it in
overnight you don't drive for 10 hours
or whatever that's 40 miles yeah but now
you're even knowing so I tried to do
that once in a while but I'm where I
live I'm lucky because I live next to a
lot of well I live next to a
supercharger and I also live next to
like Whole Foods in Whole Foods and like
a lot of places like that you just plug
in yeah yeah yeah
like a handicapped parking spot pretty
much oh yeah and it's free and I get mad
when I see a car parked there that's not
allowed I almost wanna go get the
manager like um we need to there's a
situation in the parking lot yeah
luckily the whole things by me that
they'll tell you oh good yeah they're on
top okay so I also have a lecture car I
have my pace I have a Jaguar I didn't
want to get a Tesla cuz I pull them to
the Comedy Store a lot and there's too
many Tesla right so I was like you know
what let me do my own thing and I love
the car I love driving it but this [ __ ]
charging is an issue
well yeah I'm learning because I've only
had to car for like a month so this is
new for me now this building that I live
in they're getting them right and I made
sure I that's the only reason why I got
the car oh I was gonna move I said hey
he's like no but getting up don't worry
it's free right like I do suggest people
out there you know you should you should
if you live in something the city does
do this for free that will come in
install and it gives you tax breaks I
know this kind of [ __ ] but so I don't
have it yet right so I'm it's usually
fine right I can tell you right now that
if I owned a regular electric car not a
Tesla I would sell it immediately
because of that reason because the lot
of people don't realize that
supercharger network that Tesla has huh
is worth it alone like there's all these
companies like trying to compete with
Tesla no your honor but you try to drive
to Vegas it's impossible if you don't if
you don't have a Tesla because the
supercharger you see you pull up in
there 30 minutes you got 300 miles you
ready to go
and because the superchargers are
amazing yeah that it's like well I go to
the 50 kilowatt ones and those are
discharges I get and that's you know
like you need it's in an hour you're
good right you know but into Tesla for
30 minutes you're good right now I mean
those these things are everywhere though
the other ones are everywhere - they're
growing but I actually have a problem
with Tesla just being for Tesla don't
tell me you care about the environment
[ __ ] if you if you're gonna just
have a proprietary plug just for your
cars yeah but I tell you man Tesla's
become so popular that if they opened it
up for everybody it would be mayhem they
would have to make a million more
superchargers what would stay [ __ ]
anyway they already talked about
five years that has to be cars on the
street are gonna be electric cars I
think I don't think he would have a
problem with it if all the other car
companies were like hey we'll help you
pay for all these superchargers you know
because I mean they are well I mean a
lot of the places that they have them
these are the arm wait what is that
noise sounds like a waterfall I know
it's fine you're not gonna hear it on
I'm not gonna hear it on the thing and
this is just all technical difficulties
every time that's the technical
difficulty podcast but we're good but
anyway what I'm saying is hello it's
soothing it can't have music hooked up
but anyways um if I want to cut to it
I'll do this I probably won't that's
probably gonna be in you're gonna wonder
why I just clap but [ __ ] it anyways the
the the the the I just feel like that
the other things they're everywhere
also but like today I had this issue
yeah alright so what I'm realizing that
now is like I I can't go far I gotta
have at least a hundred miles yeah I
mean it cuz I went to Burbank I had like
50 ok I had like 50 miles and I thought
I could give you bourbon no man I got
the Burbank and I got my music playing
and the air is going on every realize
all this kind of [ __ ] you know and then
I was that there I was like oh I can
only got like 15 miles left and it's
just like it goes quick when you're at 2
towards the bottom you know you're old
you also realized that when it says you
have 90 miles yeah
that's 90 miles out on a flat road no
air condition yeah yeah you know like
you're going these up and down these
hills going to Burbank oh it doubles
almost I know so then so there you are
and then so this so I went to Walmart ok
cuz excuse me oh god it was terrible I
went to Walmart and they have well I
forgot what that one's called a charge
America and it's a fast charger it
wasn't work Oh God ok so what's at
Walmart yeah then I went to uh then I
went to this other one wasn't working I
went to another one wasn't working so
then I had to go to this like bullsh to
one of the [ __ ] ones like charge
point which I just
understand why they're not all
superchargers yeah if you're if I'm in
public why if it says it takes 14 hours
this is pointless
yeah yeah it's it is point it's
pointless I don't get those why are
those even out there now because I think
what it is is that those are actually
using a almost just a look that almost
like a power outlet those things are
because yeah yeah because in order to
make it a faster charger a supercharger
it's it's a lot of work getting the
electricity lines there in the stuff
like that oh by the way I remember what
I was gonna say a lot of these with
these Tesla supercharger things they're
being paid for by the complexes because
oh yeah they put them in the malls they
put them in the malls they put in place
cuz they want business they want people
that own Tesla's to park in front of
their store they'd be like well I got 30
minutes let me go inside such-and-such
oh and it's smart because yeah well
they're not good to the Burbank mall
park my car come you know I mean
shopping I guess I go to Macy's yeah
yeah yeah right that's what you do like
I do like the idea of like it's like
almost like having a dog where you got
to go walk it so you get it you know you
get yourself my cars like that so I go
let me go right so I'll go sit in my car
and write or I'll go to the Starbucks
and I go I like that energy that that
like this is my time to do something
productive energy yeah when I got my
Tesla also I didn't sell my gas car and
I don't know if you still have a gas car
if not I recommend just holding on to
like getting a Honda Civic for a couple
thousand dollars just for emergencies
and stuff like because I kept my I was
thinking of selling it and then I was
looking at what I paid this off already
let's just see maybe keep it for a few
months see how I like the tests all
right
yeah I use that like oh I need to go to
the airport I'm leaving my car at the
airport because another thing you got to
watch out for is drain they call it
zombie drain or something like that oh
yeah so like if you park your car
overnight you come back it's gonna be
less than when you park it there
because a little things like the car
turning on and like no battery fans and
stuff like oh really yeah so you gotta
watch out for that cuz I didn't know
that at first and I drove through the
airport once and I think I had like a
hundred miles left I'm like I'm good I
get back to my car I was like 40 and I'm
like holy [ __ ] what
really happened to me I've actually
parked at the airport a couple times now
and they have the charge down there yeah
so I've just plugged in and left my car
and I come back and I have a full charge
wait where is it is it the middle part I
have it at seven six and one at LAX was
a packed was there zero it was packed
but what I realized is that the airport
actually isn't that big in my mind I
feel like three is so far away from but
actually I fly United I fly American
Park at six it's a short walk to but
it's not bad you know it's not bad so I
was like oh this is actually pretty good
and they have the ones that one two then
you have a super charger of one really
yeah check that out I was I hear that
they're getting them at the economy a
lot like lot e or whatever that new lot
is I think they're getting things there
too next twelve dollars a day so it's
like that's pretty [ __ ] good yeah I'm
the idiot that perks at the parking spot
or right over that yellow and black and
it's so expensive but I know it's so
nice because I hate like there's a
million of their shuttles yes I hate
just sitting there going where the [ __ ]
is a shuttle you know like some crazy
latin guy I was gone for a week it was
$190 so I'm like why the [ __ ] am I doing
this you can't do per any more because
of their goober problem at LAX well
that's actually not bad is it no it's
not bad it's right there and it depends
on what airline you fly it's right there
I heard it was like a 40-minute wait
just to get the uber to come get to you
because of the lines and no I thought
was I haven't even done it yet but I
bother you my told me it was easy that
it's just right there you know you're
just you know you pull up and the ubers
are just waiting and then you just put a
thing and there's a number and you put
they put their number and you put your
number in boom and you could go oh wow I
heard nine I'm gonna think that's true
huh I think people just love to [ __ ]
about things yeah well that's that
Hinchcliffe kid again no he just [ __ ]
about everything but I wish they did you
notice they move the LAX parking from
thirty to forty dollars yeah and that
makes to me it makes a difference it's
like let's say you go on a two-day Vegas
trip right am i spending $60 right but
eighty it's too much unless when I live
in Burbank so it's like I have to
balance like how much is it for an uber
and back you know which is usually about
80 bucks so if it's over 80 I'm like wah
brother up my car see I live closer to
the LA so I'm always in that calculation
in my head to where I'm like okay it's
like $25 depending on the time of day do
I want to just have my car then one time
I tried this new lot and it all these
lots man they just there's some nonsense
behind every lot yeah you know this one
like like they'll block your car then
you got a call a person who has to come
find the key and move this car and I was
like I'm out we just need a subway to
the airport you know they need to do
this [ __ ] already this city is plan so
horrible I think what's that and with
like oh let's put Hollywood Bowl on one
of the main arteries of going into town
sometimes I'm like okay I got an hour
till my spot at the college store and
nope two hours later he did hottie like
what it's The O'Jays at [ __ ]
Hollywood Bowl
it'd be one thing if it was like oh it's
Madonna I know it's the Hollywood Bowl
it's always some bull you know Mike
Buble you know it's funny as we [ __ ]
all the time or a lot of people all
bitching about the [ __ ] but that I was
just in Ohio and that was like help like
like right now it's like sleeting rain
and 20 degrees 10 degrees and I come
back I'm like more [ __ ] we're talking
about our electric car problems I'm so
sorry for you people out there who are
like probably on the bus listening on
your headphones are you at your 9 to 5
job trying to just you know we're so
sorry that these first world problems
with myself now but seriously have you
been a veggie grill lately they changed
oh man I see you you feel do you feel
really Hollywood like you know I'm doing
this new bit where I'm talking about how
like being I just think that being a I'm
a self-hating liberal you know because I
think that if to be a liberal but then
to start making money you're just living
in hypocrisy
it's just hypocrisy dude it's like you
know you you hear about the immigration
and you hear about the stuff that's
going on and
borders and all this stuff and you know
as a liberal you're like we need to help
people but then they live in gated
communities
ya know right we talk about body
positivity but they got trainers and
nutritionists and like you know it's
kind of like everyone's giving that hate
on that little girl Greta whatever her
do you know and they're like yeah but
look at this picture of her she's using
like one-time plastic like potato salad
containers like a position where she
can't do anything right yeah like she's
just in this tough position where I said
what is she supposed to do walk places
yeah backpack right like you know you
know like farmer owned food and like you
know well our own water that's that I
mean when you when you get put when you
are so passionate about something like
that you got to go all-in or you get I
don't know 16 you're passionate about
like boys and yeah it's like I know
somebody and I'm gonna say she is but
she's like the most hardcore vegan ever
where she's mad at people that do this
and that vegan and the other day she got
a new car and she was talking about how
she loves the smell of a new car and I'm
like you know that's dead leather that's
like you smell your car seats heard
she's dead animal leather don't even get
me started on vegans man I don't I don't
like animal people a period yeah like
don't come to me with your animal
[ __ ] okay like slow down Tony damn
right you know what I mean like I'm glad
you're I'm glad that these rich mostly
white people who care about animals are
around right cuz if it wasn't for them
to animal to begin ok ok so thank you
for doing that
but keep that [ __ ] to yourself mmm you
know what I mean yeah if I want to slap
a dog puppies no but I'm saying like no
you like puppies but you like too
expensive puppy that you have to yeah
you know yeah oh yeah I'm a shih tzu guy
yeah you can't get it I mean I rescue to
the pound you know you know I rescued my
dog from the second floor of the
Glendale Galleria smelled like you know
at your coronary I know I just but I'm
just saying that's what I'm saying about
like you know that's it's hard to it's
hard to listen to like rich liberals
complain about anything so you're not
you're a part of the problem
because the Middle America and the
people they're more in line with each
other
democrat or republican to me they seem
to be more in line with like a class
system as opposed to like you know these
values of these two sides because once
you start making money and they start
taking it away for taxes as when you
start to go oh oh I get what's Trump
saying tax what we do taxes what Trump
kind of [ __ ] us all comedians up you
know this this year or next year not
just comedians athletes yeah and yeah
entertainers I feel like I you know what
I feel like you did I feel like he he
sent people into a room he said find a
way to [ __ ] over liberal Hollywood yeah
on a tax thing and they come back to me
with what you got they said we got it
you can't you can't write off agents and
manage your fees you can't you know
everything you can't deduct money for
things you know man I got hit hard oh
yeah me too I can't even I can't even
imagine that this year like what's how
bad it's gonna be but one good thing is
my Tesla is a complete amazing write-off
there's this little loophole your car
work weighs more than five thousand
pounds Tesla's just way like a shitload
it could be used as like a business
vehicle of some kind and it's like most
ridiculous right off like I don't want
to say how much it is but somebody told
me it's almost 50 percent of the car how
much does a nice way yeah you're just
gonna add something plus that great
California tax break for they're having
a location which is gonna go away no
date it just went away for Tesla like I
was like the last month of that oh yeah
got to get those lead rims so your car
weighs more if it's a little low ah man
hilarious were you from originally
Columbus Ohio Columbus Ohio yeah and
then you always did you always want to
be a comedian oh no no actually what was
the great start of yours uh meaning
Rogen and Doug Stanhope
I never thought about I always wanted to
be an acting like comment like I always
liked SNL and doing my job and stuff so
I I always worked at movie theaters
growing up and stuff so I thought like
oh that's one day I may you know moved
to Hollywood and be like like a Steve
Martin type guy but then when once I met
Rogen and stanhope when I still lived in
Ohio it's like holy [ __ ] I didn't you
know I never even thought about doing
stand-up comedy though and then a lot of
people that will I met with like Joe
used to have a message board and I used
to be on this message board being like
when the moderators or whatever a lot of
the people on there we're like you know
we should all try comedy together so a
lot of us started doing open mics and I
know all these people
ya know and so I started doing open mics
in Ohio but unfortunately Ohio is like
the worst place to do stand-up comedy
there's no comedy scene there was one
comedy club yeah I don't know yeah well
the the local place that I used to do
stand-up comedy they just stopped all
the open mics like they don't they don't
do anything for where's a clone - so I
have funny bone or the funny but oh yeah
he used to have no okay no so I mean I
did it maybe like 10 times in Columbus
Ohio and then I stopped because I had a
bad set where I got booed at because I
did a Bob Hope joke and I'm like I'm
never I'm never doing this again
you did a Bob Hope joke the day he died
and oh okay but you didn't wanna Bob
Hope's Joe no no no I didn't steal I
know what's the Bob Hope Joe all right
so I've said this a lot but so the day
Bob Hope died I had to spot the open mic
and they oh they used to fill the open
mic with it there was a cross street
there was a retirement home so they
would give them tickets like hello free
tickets to a comedy show and a bus would
come and they would just drive I didn't
know that and so I come out and I was
about to do it oh my god there's old
people in the audience they're all they
all loved Bob Hope this is not gonna
work should I do it show not so I was
like [ __ ] I'm ready do it I was like
hey do you guys hear Bob Hope died today
and everyone of course
yeah I was like do you think they flew
out his body to Iraq to entertain all
the dead troops this was during the war
you know whatever war that way
weekend at Bernie's yeah glad you got
rid of that yeah exactly
I stopped and I didn't get call me for a
long time because always has that always
been your inclination is to go dark or
to go well I might the people that I
started was Brogan and Stanhope that's
the people that I grew up first time
watching you know also Chimel and so
they were Stanhope
oh yeah it's like one of the darkest
people ever and Rogan used to actually
be double super dark he's not as dark
now but he used to be super dark so I
always thought that was the the funny
[ __ ] always go dark I get you know like
shocked the audience and stuff like that
did you um but did you feel like all
this is I'm so comfortable doing this
yeah I did I because I think the
darkness was always you know I was
always an artist to when I was growing
up and I was always the guy drawing
dicks on people's no books and stuff
like that
so I had like really good really good
good shadows I made that I made the
circumcision scars look real no but so I
was always kind of like a dark humored
guy and so the biggest problem though is
I wish I didn't start off dark because
now it's hard for me to do a clean set
oh it's even now even kind of now
because I am still a dirty guy you know
like and so like when I'm you are filthy
right now if I had to write a set for
like TV I think I could probably take a
lot of my jokes and like change them a
little and I have tried that in you know
but you don't feel comfortable it just
feels out of place for me it's like oh
I'm like cleaning up I'm what am i doing
this it's not who I am I guess but you
know my humor is always like the
darkness I don't like you know there's
only a few comics I like that are clean
because if you when it's too clean I'm
like I don't I get to me it's a
specialty
yeah yeah it's a specialty and I hate
when you go suppose they're like what we
need you to be clean and I'm thinking
myself I need you to pay me more right
you just asked me to juggle yeah it's a
harder muscle because I'm not used to
doing I don't think I'm not one of these
people that's like oh we should be able
to say whatever we want and do whatever
we want I mean there is a skill to like
not sometimes I've tried it like I have
a I'll be talking to my said I'll be
doing it and I think I usually curse
here I think do I need to say [ __ ] right
here right do I need to say this or
didn't need to say like you know you
know and I've now tried to I've tried
that too but I've realized that a lot of
times I don't have that in my act it's
just me going [ __ ] you know like I don't
know you know where it's like the worst
is I try to listen to all the sets I do
and then the next day going can I stop
saying [ __ ] every five minutes what the
[ __ ] is wrong yeah no I really think it
is important about all those comics out
there it is important to like to listen
to your set you know I mean absolutely
yeah I'm just checking cuz I gotta do
everything myself so um I got a look and
see and I felt like I was like that
message it come up and I still see it
recording you know you can you know you
understand cuz you for you you'd be over
there oh yeah evidence the other people
be able to doing this and I got to do
everything I gotta like be looking at
the side of my my face to make sure that
the [ __ ] thing is recording but um I
don't know I I think as I get older I
sometimes I feel like man let me try to
find a way to not curse as much you know
and it's like I say [ __ ] a lot too I
like calling people [ __ ] yeah guys
girls whatever it's just this a good I
love the word [ __ ] yeah you know I mean
yeah you know but it's like in you know
I'll call anybody [ __ ] my mom anybody
he doesn't mean it's like whatever I
just it's a to me it's just an a
punctuation of what I'm saying but now
I'm just like okay maybe let me find a
way not at least you can catch yourself
to it like I don't even realize it I
don't realize either until I get Quincy
weekly so Quincy or sesame is like man I
I won't do a drinking game every time
you say fat [ __ ] you know just like I
like the word big [ __ ] if I'm telling
the story about a big girl and I'm like
what this big [ __ ] you know it just
rolls off the tongue fun ways I think
you should change that yes fun way of
saying fat girl you this let me tell you
what this big [ __ ] did you know and I
said I think I think that the television
and movies and stuff like that are
catching up to that I cuz I think a lot
of people have the same problems cuz
that you know the other day I was
watching TV and I didn't when did they
allow that the word butthole to start
beings
I always butthole on TV have buttholes
all the time on TV but that's not a bad
word [ __ ] no [ __ ] I feel like it's
the one you can't say but I think you
could say stop being a butthole yeah I
mean that's just weird to hear it on TV
is weird look like in friends like what
god stop being a butthole
but what what in what context I can't
remember what the content because I know
you can't say like you can't use
butthole in like as a sexual reference
no I think they said it as if like oh my
buttholes tickling oh yeah I know it's
just weird hearing it because I don't
think that used to be a thing a couple
years ago you know well I remember [ __ ]
used to be I remember as a kid watching
dynasty they used to be the big show
yeah dynasty you know and then when
she's in and then what the one character
slapped the other character and called
her a [ __ ] yeah the next day it was
like it was like [ __ ] on TV and you
know everything I remember that you know
it was like this big thing and now it's
like it we're just I'm waiting for you
know but when you look at table but not
I don't know mean like HBO or Showtime
right I'm just talking about TBS TNT I
mean they're saying [ __ ] [ __ ] like look
at South Park yeah they're saying
everything you did yeah you getting like
last night I was watching the last
episode you watch Family Guy
of course oh my god Family Guy still
kills I love it it's it's you know once
in a while it's kind of like there's
nothing to it but they still bring it
they had this Santa Claus episode where
meg take Stewie to see Santa Claus and
Stewie scared or Santa Claus so she sits
on Santa Claus lap with Stewie on her
lap and Santa's doing his knee like this
and there's she has an orgasm okay and
Meg is like what so - she's she's in
she's in love with Santa okay so she's
trying to find Santa so at the end of
the episode the real Santa comes and
he's like you know he gives her
- he balls you know and she says like
you give me your balls and then Santa
goes yes and if you rub them together
outcome episodes ended with Peter going
like this you're welcome or something
like that you know closes the book you
know but I'm like that's too kind of
have you ever done the voice a voice on
that you know I wish yeah I'm going in I
wish really the casting director doesn't
like me yeah I feel like she doesn't
like me because she always she's always
hard on me I come in just like that you
know I go this is my voice [ __ ] what do
you want me to do yeah I'm so jealous
like I know a lot of people yeah cooze
on there all the time yeah I mean
there's a few people that might how I
I'm so jealous of you because I think
that would be the best job just going oh
my god hell yeah be the best job just I
want to get on a cartoon that goes 25
years that's my dream have my own car
that's what I was doing today in a
Burbank actually as I was going on a
Nickelodeon audition for it to be a
series regular on a Nickelodeon content
perfect
yeah but Nicola that's hilarious that
you drive all the way to Burbank and I
Drive all the way here at this maybe I
should we could have done this at all
things comedy but it's hard to get it
it's hard to get a date there I have my
Studios right next to it we gotta just
done it there on location next time next
time I'll be like on location after red
man red band studios what'd you think of
being at The Comedy Store right now like
how do you like how does uh you know
like what do you you know are you
regular no I'm not a sore spot for you
you know it was for a while but now I'm
just like I don't care I don't know what
the [ __ ] is it's all politics with those
exactly yeah I mean cuz that for one
point I thought I was gonna become a
regular pretty soon oh that would the
Tommy days no Tommy did not like me
because Tommy didn't like Rogen and like
like I I remember my first time ever
doing the o.r as a development spot
right uh I get off and I was like kind
of happy I was like oh my god even Kurt
Fox comes up to me goes dude that last
jokes funny I got tagged for you
oh then everyone's gonna be posting and
then Tommy comes up and goes I look at
you are you working for your little
[ __ ] Rogen and starts going off like
calling Joe of gay
all this stuff already yelling at me
luckily my phone was still in my pocket
recording my set so the whole thing was
recorded oh wow next day we played it on
the Joe Rogan podcast
you're like look so no no I mean I I get
why people like Tommy and I was always
nice to Tommy but he would just like
once in a while I have these like
bipolar episodes on he's like what the
[ __ ] was that about you know let's do
some weird I always thought there was a
method to his madness I'd like to
believe that right you know and I don't
know I think you know people say he was
racist and all that kind of stuff but I
don't know if that's I don't know I
think he was getting appropriate I think
he was I think he was racially
inappropriate right I think there should
be other I think there's levels to
racism I thought I don't think she just
be like you either a racist or you're
not know I think if there's like some
things in there where you're like you're
not you're not as terrible you know what
I mean yeah yeah I don't and I don't get
that like the the regular thing cuz like
there was a while where you know I've
been headlining on the road for years
and stuff like that and out like I'll
have some openers and stuff and these
openers are now getting passed as a
regular somebody what the [ __ ] and then
and then like then I remember the thing
that made me go alright I don't not
giving a [ __ ] about this timorous like
like one of the people that got passed
from like why did they get passed they
they suck you know and then like oh this
person just got a commercial that's
really popular I'm like alright this is
I'm done I'm done caring about this but
no I don't know if they I don't know if
it's like I have a feeling like when I
made that Carlos Mencia video with Joe
Rogan like you know I think the Comedy
Store was really pissed off about that
because that that was their number one
moneymaker at the time as Carlos you
know really and I think you know Joe got
banned from there I think I indirectly
got banned from there because I'm the
one that made the video right I think I
don't know if somebody high up was a
slag don't let him every black listed
from being a paid regular song but I
still get development spots but I've
been getting him for days are done I
think that I think there was a lot of
people that were upset when Tommy was
removed from the club because there were
people that were in with him
absolutely that felt like they had
inroads to like soon or maybe than a
year two years they were on
so he wiped out all that right cuz in
the new person Adam is his own thing he
got his own people he's got his own
style
yeah but the club's booming yeah I don't
know I mean it's not like he ain't doing
something wrong yeah I don't know I
don't get it I mean I guess I just keep
on doing those development spots for
another year I know I've been I've been
there I've been in your shoes but so I
don't I don't even know what to say all
I can be for me is just grateful that
like I'm a part of the core of the you
know if I get to you know so I look back
and be like oh man I was a part of that
but like it's hard to say you know cuz
when I hear people talk about this I go
okay well let's look at the lineup who
we taking off the show today hmm you
know that's the hard part
yeah yeah especially in the meat of it
like you know from 9:45 to like say 11
mm-hmm like that's two people then you
have these other people that are like oh
they just got past or they're working
but they never move from here it's
harder to move from these spots now to
in this than it than ever before yeah
thing right yeah I mean I'm happy for
every one that becomes a regular you
know yeah it just makes me wonder if I
was like should I just I get a job as a
door guy I don't know but I mean but
becoming a regular doesn't mean that it
doesn't mean anything it doesn't mean
that you're actually gonna get spots
yeah yeah it's true I used to say man
laughs actor I used to be like that I
would say like the process to try to be
a regular at the Laugh Factory
you got more spots than when as you
became a regular because then it was
like alright well now you're competing
with all the people that are already
getting spots yeah I'm pretty much a
regular everywhere else but I don't
think they actually make it official at
at most places they don't go we're gonna
put your name on the wall they don't do
that I got the improv or it's a large
factory so I mean I all the other places
they they've you know I've been okay
there I'm fine over and I remember when
I first I remember I remember when I
wasn't in at the Laugh Factory I'll
never forget this I go to I just had I
was doing a gig at Hollywood improv and
I had my name on the marquee you know
and so I go to I call they hydrate I
said to the girl I go hey um what kinda
gets about she goes well Tuesday we have
a sign-up for open mic and I said to her
I said you know this is very this is
this is very bizarre to me because you
know down the street my name is on the
marquee and now you're telling me to
come sign up
your open mic right like [ __ ] you you
know what I mean like what do you think
like like commie didn't start its your
shitty-ass club I mean it's just a
building you know you have a building
with you know a sound system this isn't
where [ __ ] comedy was created you
know I mean so that's the [ __ ] we
have to go through as we're coming up so
she said to me she goes okay then she
realizes that I'm sorry you know what
what you do is you know you well Jamie
has to know you that kind of thing and
so I remember doing a show I was on
somebody show and then I along with
Chris D'Elia
and then Chris said to him while I was
on stage like hey look at my buddy and
then I got after that so you just wait
for those moments yeah I just yeah it's
it's all confusing I don't get it like
cuz when I was doing open mics in Los
Angeles I was with Chris D'Elia that was
during that time period
Dean Del Rey I know it's weird to see
like today like yesterday's open mic is
tomorrow superstar you never know what
you never know what is God now I look at
people when I go I don't know how this
work right yeah I just go hey I'm a lot
nicer to them that I used to be
especially like you know kill Tony we
get to see so many new people and oh
yeah nothing like then you like we had
preacher Lawson used to be one of the
main guys that would come every week and
sign up and now that dudes [ __ ]
highlighting all over the place and
we're gonna sell it out so you never
know so it's like that's why you just
have to have like a certain like if you
know like a Brotherhood you know you're
just like it when you see a brother
succeed you have a little bit of
jealousy because that's just normal to
be like oh man but at the same time you
have to be like good for that guy yeah
it's just hard yeah you know I mean I'm
telling your face right you're just like
I'm sure you've been at the store many
time where you've wanted her to like
trip somebody before they went onstage
just take your foot out - oh I'm here I
could do I think the biggest crazy thing
is that you know I used to me and
Tiffany would go on the road all the
time Tiffany had it now she won't even
return [ __ ] yeah oh yeah I just said I
tried the tech store the other day and
it was Green yeah
yeah that guy won't be able to get in
contact with her anymore I've had her on
the podcast yeah yeah it's so funny you
know I was like damn so I know but I
like seeing that me too
I'm you know of all the people that I
love what's happened to Tiffany because
she deserves it she's one of the
hardest-working comics ever and I was
one of the few people that like I didn't
barely knew her and I was like you know
what I want to start taking her on the
road because like she needs to be seen
you know and stuff so that was fun and
I'm so glad we did that for years you
know me and her and sometimes Toni
sometimes Dean Delray would go to all
these cities and there's a guy that
works hard man in Delray oh yeah yeah
Dean [ __ ] well I mean that guy he's
dead like 500 episodes of his podcast
too and and he writes down how many
times he gets it he probably it's up
twice or three times a night every night
with no car sometimes yeah yeah in LA
with diabetes yeah I'm gonna have him on
to oh you got it he's great it's so many
stories at this point dormant I'm a dog
the podcast is like I don't I haven't
really I haven't found my audience yet
it's weird
and it all depends on the guest yeah you
know so I'll have like a huge episode
and it'll be like oh here's my just
here's a guy that wants to be an
astronaut that I found interesting
everybody this kid that was here before
we're like well you gotta keep on doing
other people's podcast and but yeah but
you know what that does is then they
only want to see that person on my
podcast that's what I found so if I go
on Santino's podcast so Santino's people
will just want to see him they don't
want to see anything you know what
Bobby's people and start some drama I
know I gotta yeah I have to dance with
my you know dance with my shirt off oh
God do a music video those guys Jesus
it's not ridiculous Bert is a master at
[ __ ] marketing oh he really is and
there's nobody better at mark yeah and
that guy and it you know you're a master
something when you're even annoying your
friends though because I don't know how
many times like him like Jeremiah is
another one I think Jeremiah is on top
of his game of self-promotion but it
so annoying when you're around that and
you're just like every three minutes
he's like holding his phone hey guys
well in Columbus Ohio you're just like
dude shoot me I don't want you to see
the ad but definitely got it obvious
what you got to do what else are we
supposed to do yeah
I can't oh did I I got into a fight with
a comic I'm not gonna say his name but
he like sent a mass text to everybody in
his phone book okay hey I got a show
come to my you know the and I wrote him
back I replied like yell bro I got my
own shitty show to promote right I don't
need this in my type send this to your
fans okay okay you don't mean like don't
send out other comics yes and what was a
funny part about it is like because I
also replied all like I was like son of
a [ __ ] so all these comics are hitting
me up secretly like oh man yeah that was
annoying but they're not telling him
that I think I know your attack so I
came across as the [ __ ] and him and
I didn't talk for a year or whatever it
is like that and I was like whoa and he
was like so mad about it I was like bro
no but this this is whew yeah okay you
don't do that there has to be a way to
get to opt out of these group texts also
you know like why is it there like get
me out of here by just Facebook used to
be like this too or they would just have
this like you could just be a part of
someone's group yeah I didn't accept
your group I don't want to be a part of
your whatever the [ __ ] your group is
right sorry forgot it's the worst yeah
man
group text one time this girl texted I
was seeing her like whatever it was a
long time ago and she texts it like a
bunch of people and I don't think she
knew she was doing it oh yeah it's a lot
you know and I was like so hey what's
going on you know and then she was like
you know but then everybody started
texting and another was other dudes in
there too where I was like so who's
going out with our next you know she
like blocked me and turn it to a whole
thing but I was like [ __ ] you get your
game right sometimes it's a good thing
there like a
remember during the patent troll days I
don't know if you remember that like
somebody's doing a trying to patent
troll podcast like they and if they won
they would have owned like all the
podcasts that you never saw ever get in
like Adam Carolla was a big like
defender of it I think he paid to fight
this and stuff in one but I think they
during that time somebody reached out to
all the podcasters in like a group email
like some management company like trying
like hey you know we all have to work
together and one person like like
replied all somehow I got a part of it
and I'm like holy [ __ ] I think I've
Seinfeld's email now it's just I'm amber
I see being an Android a lot before I
switch over to Apple but used to be able
to like you could put you could text
someone you could text 10 people at once
mmm remember that yeah separately
separately right right but you met you
had to make sure you click that yeah
yeah see see or whatever yes so I used
to like one in my in my player days if
that was like a thing I wouldn't look at
me I'm not really a player but you know
daddy was on TV and stuff I would you
know I text 10 girls what's up girl
that's dangerous you know one time I did
go to like I bet a mistake so those ten
will remove from then but then people
start to get on it I think people got
smarter because some girls would be like
you know you just are saying my name and
I will watch a generic text hello user
are you doing tonight
command code thing right I wish they had
that that be done so great right can't
wait to see you again such-and-such and
then like you it then there's like a
nickname randomizer you could maybe you
could put five nicknames and then they
just randomizes you know boo boo sweet
sweet things that's so funny you just
remind me of something like I think cuz
you know when I do a lot of shows like I
put together
it shows and sometimes I'll send a
message and I forget who it was but as a
female mic hey boo what are you doing
Friday can you do one do this show and
blah blah and I remember like a lot of
times I'll just copy and paste and send
it something else you know like and I
didn't forgot that I put the boo on
Philbert somebody like speaking of it
would you watch Mandalorian yes but I
have not watched the last watch I loved
it so much you know why cuz I know how
he's such a like a guy guy like he's not
a nerd right right okay so Freddie has
this line anywhere he says like I was
never a stormtrooper and he says it was
such passion that I was like oh this is
this is enemies it's amazing to see like
a dude like that be in my I texted him I
was like you made my nerd heart sing I
love that that show exists because it
really makes me excited about Star Wars
again cuz you know that lately these
movies have not been cutting it and I
think this series is probably better
than any of the Star Wars stuff that's
come out oh yeah yeah yeah maybe rogue
one yeah other than rogue right I
totally agree with you and go away buddy
hold on I gotta get the Ximena singing
my Star Wars talk I love it yes like
nerd time and we're gonna turn out on
Star Wars
yeah it's I mean what's crazy is I even
see that this is becoming bigger that
like as big as like like Sopranos or
something yeah I totally agree I I think
it's that good
I there's I don't know what it is if
it's the music if it's the camera angle
because it's a lack of CGI it's like
well but I don't mind sometimes you
don't even realize when I CGI that's
that's what CGI is good because there's
a lot of CGI in that show right they're
not in these places yet but like like
like baby Yoda right that's a puppet
right that's what makes the CGI that
they do have you not stand out but
anyways there's something about we don't
know who this guy is but but I feel
emotions mm-hmm you don't mean it's so
well done
do you hear the theory that he's gonna
take off that mask and it's gonna be Jar
Jar Binks oh well that's what this is
just funny that uh bill burr makes that
joke oh yeah
what are you a gunden under there and
she makes a joke about it yeah that's
hilarious like they're making fun of
themselves what's what I like but I know
I tell you it is it's a very exciting I
I love I just think that some of them
are boring mmm I think that you could
have combined like I would I want an
hour give me 45 minutes yeah I get that
but I also get my I get I don't know
nowadays it's hard for me to sit down
and watch an hour show first really I I
get I get a like I need to think you
missed out on something else so I kind
of like this thirty to forty minute it's
all it feels so easy like I like I could
ill miss give me a break I mean 45
minutes though oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah if you're doing the commercial hour
yeah no no no I mean like could there's
no commercials so just be me give me a
smile at 40 to 45 minutes on the show oh
yeah
because sometimes I go there was one
episode where I was like that was
useless episode yeah I didn't need all
this and sometimes and then sometimes I
feel like the actions soak it's so quick
and so you know intense for you like
then it's like he's flying off and
you're like well they're gone again
you know yeah the sad thing is a well I
saw it coming kind of his the reviews
for the new Star Wars movie came out
today but write a bad review yeah one of
the things I said I read was the worst
Star Wars movie ever made
Wow and and a lot of people were talking
about yesterday like Disney when it
didn't invite George Lucas to the
premiere that's very Tom I think so I
think there's no telling I think they
know that they have a hot finish it did
they did they I don't like how
dismantled everything is how fractured
the you know you gotta you got to have a
cohesive grooving unit more who's the
only one that got it right to MCU people
yeah
they're the only ones that had a vision
and follow through with it they were
like here's what we're gonna do we're
gonna build this up and then and they
made two of the greatest action movies
ever with with great actors and it's
like they had that with Star Wars and
they just been ruining it day after day
and movie after movie after movie but
maybe they'll get it right with this
Mandalorian you know I
I'm gonna watch Star Wars I'm gonna
watch the movie yeah meat yeah me too I
mean I just I saw the Dane Cook went to
the premiere and some I texted I said
what you think it a movie you know and
he he had something good to say about it
oh yeah yeah he was so that's good he
said it was like one of the best movies
he's the best star but obviously that's
good so I don't know I don't know cuz I
hated the last one which one right
before yeah I hated that one too I
didn't like that what'd you get I just
do with the casino and the [ __ ] what
what yeah what do we do what are we
doing here in any kind of they try to
like any kind of political commentary
type of [ __ ] where it's obviously
analogous to like our world I'm like hey
[ __ ] you yeah
stick stick with your Star Wars [ __ ] cuz
I'm not trying to learn politics from
from you [ __ ] liberal [ __ ] making
these movies you know what I mean
keep that [ __ ] to yourself [ __ ] yeah
you know I just just make me laugh make
me cry make me like [ __ ] to escape
the reality you know they've already
started filming season two because I
know that because I know yeah I know
come on people that are in it yeah
they're doing a lot of comics which is
another cool thing you know why cuz cuz
comics are nerds they appreciate start
with yes and it's more realistic actors
so I am looking forward to seeing that
now have you watch any other nerd shows
are you watching Watchmen no I've been
really bad lately I highly recommend
what I heard that was good yeah and
here's a things you about it you have to
watch the whole thing and now I
appreciate it
after seeing the end mm-hmm I appreciate
it more because as you go on it's like
day day day they pose questions and you
leave the episode like what the [ __ ]
just happened
what does this show about for the next
one they might answer one and then pose
three more and then it just keeps going
and going and then there's an episode
where they explain it all and you're
like oh and then they end it it's great
yeah I want to do that I'm a huge
Westworld guy I loved West Road
yuck but I'd the last season I didn't
really like it so much but that one the
out on westward route yeah I don't walk
in that last season No
out cuz I don't want I don't care about
emo robots I don't care about emo robot
I like the idea what what's the idea
they did these robots like a no [ __ ]
hit hit hit erased on the hard drive
this is the whole reason why we go in
this place I'm going this place so I
could be a superhero and I can [ __ ] bad
[ __ ] you know and so you making them
feel as [ __ ] that now we're in the wrong
right everybody that goes to west world
in that universe is in the wrong because
these things are real why would you do
that I don't know and I'm fascinated
with that kind of stuff that I love a
robot stuff and simulation theory type
AI stuff yeah that thing I'm watching
now I love that that series the toys and
then how it's the movies [ __ ] what's it
called well [ __ ] it
it's the one where they just they they
do deep dives on they did a lot on toys
the toys we grew up with oh and now it's
the movies we grow up with like and I
would say now the movies you grow up
with this very interesting I even
watched the Dirty Dancing one and
learned a lot it oh really
yeah but they had some cool things I
didn't know like ghostbusters
like originally was supposed to be
Belushi and Eddie Murphy and Dan Aykroyd
I had no idea I never heard that before
and then at the last minute they had to
like get Bill Murray and can you imagine
if it was Eddie Murphy was it
Ghostbuster though that I think it still
would've been great it would be amazing
yeah I can't wait for Eddie Murphy to
come back yeah like supposedly he was
gonna do it this month like start
hitting the clubs
oh no and made them bad a mistake about
a month ago Comedy Store tweets surprise
headliner in the belly room this Sunday
hasn't been in the club for years this
will sell out and so I've never bought a
ticket at The Comedy Store
right I was like oh my god that's Eddie
Murphy I know it is bought the ticket
then then I literally The Improv tweets
hey surprise headliner this Wednesday
Erik Griffin's coming in or no no one of
the Wayans brothers Wayans where there's
this thank you for buying a ticket but
the whole thing is just one of the wings
yeah it was like
I know you know what I want I'm looking
forward to like being on the in eor and
then I'm like who's next Jeff and he
comes gonna be a little note and it says
Eddie Murphy oh my god can you imagine
uh-huh
I don't I was gonna be like that's cuz
there's a reason why I started doing
comedy I want to bring him up I love him
watching the him on HBO back in the day
him and Eddie uh or uh [ __ ] what's his
name Jeanne [ __ ] I can't even think
right now Rob Robin Williams him and
Robin Williams his to look at you would
do laughs reference that's great I love
you the you you just now touched my
heart right with that right there he was
the genie
you could win Mork and Mindy I love
Morgan Minnie growing up also yeah me
too I wonder when those egg shares so
bad that's one thing I've always wanted
still made or or you want the original
no they still sell them know where they
have like stereos no I I like I say man
I'm really looking forward to seeing
Eddie Murphy get back into it because we
know the process of stand-up so it's
interesting to see like what he's good
because he's such a funny guy
mm-hm like he's actually now that like
the the old elder statesman of comedy
now cuz you know cuz Cosby we've removed
him from society yeah now it's like
Eddie Murphy is that guy now he really
is you know and you think this is the
perfect time for him to come back to
especially with the success of Chappelle
and stuff like that yeah imagine if he
got back on like you know dusted off his
red jacket or whatever yeah he would
kill it like it's I think people would
accept him hardcore because a lot of
these people don't even know that he's a
brilliant comic they know that records
right right right yeah but you know
we'll see you know cuz he only really
did stand up publicly three times that's
true if you think about it yeah it's not
like he has a huge body of work as a
stand-up man he does more music tens
count he was just that brilliant as like
you know as a dynamic performer hat he
was great I always felt like stand-up
wasn't enough for him I felt that way
about like a guy like Jim Carrey two
stand-ups not enough for Jim Carrey cuz
he needs a four dimensional work you
know I mean but he
can't just be standing there and not
having prompts and things to react to
and and things to do I mean the guys so
like you know out there but I feel like
Eddie Murphy's personality was the same
kind of thing yeah
and I look forward to I wonder what he's
gonna talk about it's like because he's
so weird he's so like he stays at home
you know would be sad if he couldn't get
back in into it you know would you be
surprised wouldn't be somebody's either
because you can you imagine
I mean you that's like starting back
from scratch oh yeah I think only the
comics I don't think I always think true
comics are kind of in a wait-and-see
mode kind of just like I hope you know
me like that works out you know I want
it to work out I want to see him come
back and just blow us all the way you
know what I mean
but like you know look at like
Seinfeld's last special like I don't
know like III wasn't a it wasn't my
favorite you know things that he's done
you know I'll say is it was horrible you
know I just it was like well these
things but he's one of those guys you go
this is one of our Giants and what
mobile you can't you know it don't
matter you can't just be a giant and
they do yeah whatever the [ __ ] you want
right you know so I want I think that we
want Eddie Murphy to come back and we
want him to be great I don't and I don't
think he I don't think he would put the
time in as much as like I think after a
couple months he's like if it doesn't
work out it's not gonna work it I don't
see him like struck dude me too I feel
like he's always had a real healthy
respect for stand up and this to reason
why he never just pops in and goes
onstage like a [ __ ] [ __ ] or some
of these guys and they're up there like
so what do you guys want to talk about
well these [ __ ] you know go do do your
AG [ __ ] yeah it makes me so mad yeah I
heard about one recently at the Comedy
Store and I love this guy and I heard he
did that he like didn't have anything he
just kind of came up there I don't want
that I would go up in like you know blow
us away man but be like wow this is why
I want to get to that point yeah I mean
but that's what that's how hard this
really is like to like to really capture
that essence of what we're talking about
it who we are and what you know it take
it that's not a like fly-by-night man
and if you take a week off you go back a
lot you know you
you know I'm dusty fast that's why I'm
wondering if he's gonna be like it's
gonna be a thing where he's gonna be in
the belly room every night or it's gonna
be like it'd be like some exclusive I
can't see him do that I can't I can see
him doing it but not every night like I
can see him coming to the Comedy Store
every night and even if he's just
watching and I could see him just being
like because you keep caught up in the
environment of the Comedy Store
you know and it's gonna he's he's a
giant and I can start look dude
sometimes Chris Rock is just walking in
the hallway yeah and people it's like
that's what I learned are like giants
like you know top ten of all time you
know what I mean and he's just walking
in the hallway so yes he gets to the
point where he's so comfortable at the
comedy stores and it's like that but
what I don't know what I'm not gonna
like about any Murphy coming back is all
those [ __ ] coming yeah it would align
its gonna be like Arsenio Hall all you
know yeah I would love to see Steve
Martin try it again now I was a huge
Steve Martin fan growing up and I get
why he quit but he's too off the path
Derrick but he was I thought to myself
to the he was one of those guys to this
day and it wasn't enough yeah he just he
always was doing more yeah you know he
just Adam Sandler same thing Adam
Sandler I wouldn't consider a great
comic like these guys right but
meticulous I just had a meeting at his
office and he had all this [ __ ] on his
office wall it was for his stand-up Wow
so he really works on it in a way that I
was like man I don't work hard enough
because it's like here's the premises
and here's how it's gonna go and I want
to do this I'm gonna go there like like
like one of those like FBI the strange
it was something like that somehow his
vision board a vision board but what I'm
saying for him though it's like he it
was never enough for him either
cuz he was doing music and he just he's
just a dynamic he needs to he has to
interact with people you know he needs
that like that environment to he shines
he pops so I hoped it like I said I
hoped if any Murphy comes back he has
the you know that thing to be great at
it again
me too you know I'm gonna support him
though cuz he's great I want him to
succeed but I you know he's I saw an
interview with him recently
like what
woody what has he been doing for you
know the past couple years he's just
like you know hanging out at my house
with my kids yes funny he just had a
grandkid and that new kid of his own Wow
yeah so this he has a lot of kid look 11
kids yeah I tried to follow a couple of
them like on Twitter like a creep and I
was like holy [ __ ] how many are there
remember that one guy the fake one the
fake any Murphy son oh I thought that
was a fake prior son well I think it was
to do Island fake anymore maybe it's the
same guy he was doing it twice ah but
there was one guy claiming to be Eddie
Murphy's son I remember this was
specifically claiming to be Eddie
Murphy's son because he was they had a
little like fake press conference like
he was gonna sue him okay people are
crazy
listen I know you got to go I'm glad you
came on I wish we would have started
earlier to clay I actually have you know
we weren't sure first you know it's like
it's like I get the podcast game was
like there were you like you sit down
with someone you go we haven't gotten to
the video game no Xbox or to know I have
a house it look it looks like a computer
tower oh my god like you know what I'm
gonna put a picture of it right here you
know I wanna see that I love me too
I love it I love all of it yeah I got my
green screen right here that's not a
video game you know so great we got we
got a game sometime yeah I do late night
gaming switch switches really I love it
they do another thing I gotta do yeah
but you s you're not a Mario guy call of
duty okay yeah I love colleges I want a
mission to win a solo - solo victory
call of duty and I'm on I'm on my 43rd
try wow I haven't done it yet
Wow innocent and the fans love watching
me they love clowning me in the chitchat
okay let I do this thing where I call
chat wrap so like their fans write write
rhymes and then these beats do people
send in I do the rhymes at the end oh
that's great yeah it's called a chat
wrap so I'll check it out that's awesome
so but anyways you I'm gonna game with
this guy I'm gonna
anyone again I'll come to you we'll do a
remote episode of oral your pocket I
have a lot of I'm doing two more today
oh [ __ ] okay so this guy's gotta go he's
got to do pop more podcast yeah I can't
store but I do thank you for coming on
I'll have all of red bands information
right on below there as usual and I
thank you guys for listening and you
know make sure you subscribe and buddy I
mean I'm really I'm glad you came out I
feel like I feel like now when I see
we're gonna be talking more hell yeah
you don't I mean I like that a lot
anyways once again red band everybody
thanks for coming thanks for watching me
from a Griffin and I see you next week